i always wondered this because i i've
been following your work forever and i
don't know i don't know i always wanted
to know how much gets back to the actor
but on sunday night when the super bowl
aired the spot for doctor strange ii
your name started trending because
people were like is that patrick stewart
in doctor strange too i'm not going to
ask you if you're next i know you can't
answer it but i just wanted to know like
does that get back to you do you know
you're trending do you know people are
like hey he's in this movie or like can
you even say anything about it at all
i
i don't look at a lot of social media
and that is mostly a time issue
but um i must say before bedtime on
sunday evening
i had had plenty of communications
friends and some people i hardly knew at
all of making reference to
is that you
is that you
well of course you know
i was just at home
waiting to watch football so yeah how
could it possibly have been me so um i i
we'll have to wait and see what we well
i hope so this has been an honor thank
you for your time